[Music]
okay first of all I'm extremely
impressed with you if you wanna talk
about hustle it is the people that will
show up in a dark room when it's totally
gorgeous outside on the summer Friday so
I am very very grateful that you're here
and over the course of the next 20
minutes or so I hope that I can serve
you in some small way where you get some
nugget of wisdom or something that will
help you on your entrepreneurial
endeavors
I can tell you that I'm going to share
what I have done right and what I have
done wrong both have been equally
valuable and that was a good intro I
hope there's anybody here familiar with
the selling about family a brand
oh good thank you I'm so glad this is
we're about a lot more than accessories
we're really a family of brands across
different women's lifestyle categories
we have two accessories brands and a
skin care cosmetics brand and we have
50,000 independent business owners in
six different countries that have earned
over five hundred million dollars in
flexible earnings by selling our
products on our social selling platform
so it's probably not what you were
imagining in terms of an old-school
direct sales business that was the goal
of this business so by way of
introduction I want to just talk about
what I mean by community which is really
business that's there to serve a group
of people of movement when I think of
community I don't think about a Facebook
group though we certainly use many of
them but when I think about being
community driven and purpose driven it's
about having a business with a different
center that doesn't think about of
course we think about profitability and
everything else that a business should
but it's not our primary purpose so this
is how we began I know what you're
thinking that those children are
adorable and boy that looks like a dump
and those are both true I had been a
ecommerce entrepreneur before and and I
can tell you the journey for one to the
other was kind of crazy I think every
overnight success story takes about
seven years and that's certainly what it
was for me I was here I graduated
entrepreneur in many ways and I know
that easy and entrepreneur don't
typically go together but when you think
about the stars aligning and the
and history a time I was born you know
in this country I graduated from
Stanford in 1994 at the advent of the
Internet the first time that women were
earning degrees equal to men and
everything was a start-up so I went into
technology startups and I did a lot of
entrepreneurs do they and what I then
went back to Stanford Business School
and dropped out to start the company
that would become wedding channel comm
and I went at that business with my head
and I looked at every framework and said
where's a large addressable market space
that you could disrupt with technology
this was the early days of e-commerce it
was about aggregating price and
availability to bring wedding gift
registry online and and that business
worked and it worked so well we were on
Oprah for being great entrepreneurs and
all these women reached out to me and
said you know it was an Oprah eyes do of
the story so it was like she loves
shopping so she started this business
this is actually not what happens but
people reached out and said how do I
start this business and I honestly
thought that all I could offer was I had
raised over 120 million in venture
capital
I worked seven days a week and all I
could think was I don't on this business
this business runs me I'm honestly I'm
like this businesses but it's like
I can tell you what you should do is
don't do this I really thought to myself
how could I be so successful and in what
you're supposed to be pursuing as an
entrepreneur and actually feel like a
fraud and I and every metric that you
wanted to check off the business checked
off so I said to myself hold on I'm
wired to hustle for sure
I'm an entrepreneur by trade I look at
the world and I just see the way that I
want it to be instead of the way that it
is and I become endlessly obsessed with
making it so but if I'm gonna do that it
better be for a purpose and that purpose
better not be to just create liquidity
for the different people on the cap
table so I decided to go at it again
very differently and being mission and
community driven and really saying what
are my passions and for then and at that
time I had this serendipitous experience
of discovering direct sales I was
staying at the Adolphus of Tallinn
Dallas has anyone been there it's kind
of old and creepy a bit like this
theater but like the elevators are this
big so if you
in the elevator you were like making out
with the other person in the elevator
like this is intense and I was there
with these women that were pink caddy
drivers they were with Mary Kay they had
sashes and Tiaras and they were clearly
very very successful it was clearly a
community it was a business where it was
about more than makeup it was clearly
about people and I could see their joy
and their expression and and I was in
this business in this world for all it
was was about growth and challenge and
even if we were growing we weren't
growing enough and I thought to myself
you know that's the business I want to
be in it's a people business and I'm so
curious about it now I thought it was a
pyramid scheme that was stuffing
inventory into closets and had a lot of
false promises and honestly a lot of
that was actually accurate and it scared
the crap out of me meaning I thought
there's no way I could go into a
business like that because what would
people think right here I was the poster
child for the e-commerce and then I was
gonna go start this crazy industry but I
realized that that wasn't the reason why
I couldn't shouldn't do it that was the
reason why I had to and I wanted to
change it and I wanted to use what I
learned as an entrepreneur and really go
in and reinvent what that meant I went
to this conference this industry
conference and learn to learn about what
is you know how do I do anything in
direct sales I think that's what you do
as an entrepreneur right you crack a
book you go to a conference like this
you talk to people you ask questions you
soak it in because you start knowing
nothing and then you just figure out a
little bit as you go and what really got
me was when I went to this conference it
was all it's supposed to be about the
mission everybody's tagline every
mission that was print painted on every
corporate offices wall was about being
the company for women or serving this
but then when you talk to their
executives it didn't really feel that
way it didn't really seem authentic and
I just continued to do more research
about the industry these are big
companies I mean these are a hundred
billion dollar global industry with lots
of multi-billion dollar companies in it
and I looked at and said you know the
founding story of this business is
really important and it's not going to
look like going to raise venture capital
which is a good thing because I don't
want to do that anyway so there's the
first way you really create a community
is with totally authenticity you don't
start by being a community leader you
start by being a community member so for
me that meant being someone the business
is ultimately to serve it's
it's really not what you're thinking in
terms of 80% of our business owners have
other full or part-time jobs they're
doctors they're lawyers they're teachers
they're not just the stay-at-home mom
that is really how the industry started
in the 50s these are very much
professional level women that have a
sidekick it's their side hustle and but
what I realized is I needed to start
this business this founding story needed
to be me working another job nice and
weekends
out of my living room while I was
pregnant with my first child so it may
have seemed crazy and in a way it was
but that the actual authentic roots of
our business now anybody who's doing
this and I can understand their struggle
because I've been there and I've done it
so that was really important and then
also allowed me to bootstrap the
business so unlike the first company I
decided to bootstrap this one we raised
nothing more than two million bucks I
funded it myself for a while and then I
brought in a couple other investors but
with all the the concept of being an LLC
and buying and holding the business and
we've were over a couple hundred million
dollars in revenue we've been profitable
ever since and we never took more than
two million in capital to build the
business because it was community driven
and community driven when you think
about how do I go acquire a customer and
so often you think to that about like
well how do i acquire a customer how am
I gonna get them online how is it gonna
be viral I'll tell you how you acquire
customer to really borrow away he walk
into their living room and you go
door-to-door and I really literally mean
that when I started in was a community
member I started with the product trying
to sell it even though you know and so I
think that's really really important is
to always be a member and stay a member
and have authentic interactions the
other thing about being a community is
you have to be simple to join and quick
to connect when you have a user or a
registered email or even a customer with
the first-time purchase see them as a
member in waiting but Rick nobody
connects with a courser re-introduction
they really bond when there is a true
connection so as a tribe of sellers
these these 50,000 people again in six
countries and the things that we do
right if you're walking into a standout
conference or a keep collective
conference or an ever conference we
would use every tactic and device that's
a part of human nature to connect them
to the tribe there
is a dance that we learned there is a
song that we learned it was as close as
you can get to having a secret handshake
because if you're inside of a community
you're a member you feel like you belong
it's like what church is about right you
sing songs you but ritual if you live in
a particular town you know things that
people that don't live there don't you
know don't know and so that's that's
really important about when you're
thinking about the community is can the
community can't just be about a
commercial purpose it has to have
rituals and customs and things like that
so so that's the other thing that we're
really doing is that recognizing that in
real life really matters it's even think
you've probably seen and read all the
statistics that people are more
connected than ever but actually
lonelier than ever do you know that
bowling is up as a hobby but more people
are bowling alone this is very sad sad
but true
and so in real life is really critical
the more we're we're a tech company as
much as we're people companies so we
build these social selling apps that
allow them to connect a lot of our
businesses are driven online but we do a
lot to do things to get people to meet
up in person because that community
element is really really valuable and I
know that's why the hustle does this
conference here and it really matters so
the other thing to think about that's so
counterintuitive to what you think about
is in business everybody's heard about
the Pareto principle and that it's the
top 20 percent that will drive your
revenue that you got to focus on the
matter but if you're gonna be a real
community you got to worry about the 80%
a community isn't a group of people it's
about the one if you can make that one
person feel celebrated and special and
included when that one person does
something small everybody else watches
and knows that you truly truly care if
you only celebrate the heroes the top
contributors the top sellers the top
leaders then everybody else feels
unimportant and you know who the top
people are there to impress everybody
else so you really can't have people
that thrive as outliers in a community
without loving the one and loving the
whole and are really our whole business
is built on that because we're there for
big income we really focus on funding a
need so there are people who will come
in earn some money to pay for a
fertility treatment and then they're out
and we see them as equally successful as
the woman who earns
hundred thousand dollars a year and we
celebrate each of those successes really
in that I think that's really really
important
be transparent fair and easy to forgive
you can't really outsource managing
community to other people and I'll make
this to like if it's personal it's
personal you're a member of the
community you guys say a member of the
community and with things like this I'll
give you a very tactical and specific
example we've had things keep collective
as a term business you'd be amazed at
how large that type of business can be
one of our charms and I hope you love
this is it's a collectible it has a lot
of heart and humor and it's anybody know
what a Red Solo Cup is does anybody not
know what a Red Solo Cup is okay so we
have limited edition charms one was a
Red Solo Cup
just like our working snow globe it
sells out like hotcakes
and then we'll like turn up on eBay for
a great a great premium but this red cup
that goes crazy and sells out people
love having scarcity demand and they
love it about product but they're
furious if they've lost a sale because
of it our community was going to be
outraged that we kept running out of
stock of these these items even though
collectability was the point so we bring
in our leaders and we teach them
inventory planning we give them total
visibility to the buy process and the
ranking process so if you can bring your
community truly on the inside and treat
them as a business partner and be
transparent and when you send out an
apology you don't make a memo you go
live with video and you let them see
that when they're stressed you feel the
stress but you give them the why they'll
be on your side and it's a really
important element of community so then
the last thing about community that is
is really important is that business is
nothing more than people business would
be so easy and I thought I if I wrote a
book about business it would be dr.
Seuss style and would be like I've got
problems here problems there problems
everywhere because the reality is if
you've got products and you've got
people you have got problems but without
without either you also don't have a
business and it people if they come
together they can solve all those
problems but people are these incredibly
beautifully complex in crisis often
people and so they come into your
community and they'll vent and they'll
do
crazy things and they'll you know out
loud complain about things and so that
can lead you to want a sensor so in our
community I'll give you an example in
our in our skincare brand right we have
a phenomenal product it's clinical grade
it has lots of efficacy its
award-winning it's got all these other
things but in any large sample size
you're gonna have somebody who has an a
rash to this ingredient and you
guarantee that person's gonna post the
picture in jewelry we have the industry
standard industry defect rate is 14% are
just 3% we over invest in quality but
the entire 3% seem to come online and
post a picture robbing you know robbing
everybody else or the confidence and the
quality you have to continually message
the numbers and the Cystic saying yes
thank you so much for sharing that photo
we want you to know here are the numbers
here's the stats because you have to
protect the community
but without censoring it because
censoring will backfire this is a world
of a glass house and transparency and a
few sensor here a private community crop
soap over here and and you and you lose
the trust of your community so we are
live in a world now where it's truly
power the people and you've got to have
all your all your dirty laundry is out
there for everybody to see and you just
got to be out there and you've just got
to own it then the last thing I'll say
about the community is that when you
have a community and it's personal and
you love it you'll lose people and
they'll come and go and when they do you
have to do nothing but show gratitude
and when they complain you have to show
nothing but gratitude because in the end
of the day your best mentor is your
customer you're in your best critic is
got a gift to offer you but if you
listen with a sense of we went on
offense instead of defense then your
community will be the people that guide
you and it's not just not having a
vision on your own and giving them what
they don't even know they want but if
you truly listen to the naysayers you
know you there's something to learn you
don't want them sit in the front row you
don't let them dominate the conversation
but you can't ignore them either and
most importantly it's to help you really
learn to shape so that you can serve
your community better so I hope that
with all this today you got something
out of it that can serve you and your
business together and then the last
thing I'll tell you if there's
lessons that you want to know they're in
that book and the entire proceeds of the
book go to supporting women's education
so thank you so much for being here and
I hope you enjoy your hustle
[Applause]